[Applause]
[Music]
combat talk with the king here we go
guys this is the fight that I've been
waiting for all year Shawn Porter vs.
Danny Garcia Danny Garcia versus Shawn
Porter I don't care how you said you
have to former welterweight champions
that's going inside the ring to do
combat tonight in a few hours you're
gonna get a chance to see what I believe
maybe fight of the year okay
Danny Garcia what'd you get him Danny
Garcia is you get a pure boxer puncher
all right
Philly style traditional he can move he
can punch he can box his background is
littered with former champions and
current champions Shawn Porter is
unorthodox
some say amateurish and his approach to
his fighting I will get into why that is
and he gives you relentless pressure so
you can see that these two guys are made
for each other it's a fight made in
heaven
a counter puncher versus a pure
aggressive fighter so that's bound to
make fireworks sparks all over the place
okay I think from round one being that
Shawn Porter is so tenacious that it's
gonna start off from round one but let's
get into a little bit of the background
of both fighters
all right so Danny Garcia lost his belt
to keep Thurman now when he was fighting
Keith Thurman that was a split decision
a split decision is if you don't know is
if one judge is three judges if one
judge have it in your favor another
judge has it in the opponent's favor and
then the neutral judge takes it and puts
it in an opponent favor their way the
opponent gets the victory on a split
decision
Shawn Porter lost to Keith Thurman
majority decision that means all three
judges sore it in favor of Keith Thurman
okay
now this is how I'm gonna base both of
my predictions well one of my
predictions and my reality to the
outcome of the fight when they both
forth keep Thurman Danny Garcia is
natural he doesn't have to work hard for
what his boxing intuition tells him you
understand his body already knows
exactly when you throw the one-two you
throw the three you step over to the
left and you hook to the body you bring
the right over the top and you stay
responsible on defense if he throws a
left hand you counter with a straight
right you have to understand these
things are fundamental and box and these
are principles that have actually made
champions and broken champions Shawn
Porter is a former collegiate football
player amateur football player and he's
an athlete you understand that has
converted into boxing and he has done a
great job and becoming a champion
neither one of their trainers which is
both of their fathers each one father is
training them all right has ever been a
champion Shawn Porter father
participated was a contender and
kickboxing and you can tell from his
grounded stance it's very wide the way
he attacks is very amateurish Alec into
kickboxing now when these two combatants
get into the ring they both have
something that is a floor and the floor
and Danny Garcia is he believes that he
is stronger than Shawn Porter the floor
that's inside Shawn Porter is that he
feel he can outbox Danny Garcia both of
these individuals are wrong and the
quicker the one individual or either
both individuals find out that they are
wrong to change the game plan to go with
a different strategy the better off they
would be and Danny Garcia is a
and in in in his case he will find out
very early that Shawn Porter is the
stronger individual he does not punch
harder than Danny Garcia cos Danny
Garcia is a sharp counter puncher that
can take you out of there with either
hand axe Brandon Rios straight right
hand over the top put Brandon Rios to
sleep Brandon Rios has never been
knocked out to the head ever okay Danny
put him out all right now Shawn Porter
he's gonna realize that as the fight
goes on Danny is going to become sharper
his boxing skills is gonna start to tell
he's going to start hitting them with
combinations once Danny establishes the
jab that's when the fight turns left so
Shawn will have to have a different
strategy in order to gain victory now
what I see happening in this fight both
fighters made weight the 147 more for
this WBC belt all right so what I see
happening here is being that Shawn
Porter being that he's an athlete and
his style is an aggressive style it
always seems that he has to work two to
three times harder than a normal boxer
all right and which Danny Garcia it
comes very natural I see this fight
going the distance I see Danny Garcia
winning a majority decision
I see Shawn Porter being very mark
they're very lumped up my getting
knocked down in this fight but I don't
see because of the pedigree of the two
individuals I don't see a knock out I
don't see a stoppage if there is a
knockout and if there is a stoppage
Danny Garcia has knocked out Shawn
Porter Shawn Porter I doesn't I don't
feel that he has the boxing pedigree to
stop a Danny Garcia in every last show
Shawn Porter step up fight he came up
short every last one of them okay when
he stepped up to fight Keith Thurman he
lost
he stepped up to fight the kid from
England
he lost oh you got to understand in this
sport when those step of fights come you
got a Passover flying colors and that's
your pedigree all right so yes he's
great he's a great athlete but in this
fight he loses
I picked Danny Garcia 12-round decision
its combat talk with the king I catch
you guys later for the results show
[Applause]
[Music]